ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen seit
Tagen brodelt es in Iran immer wütender
werden die Proteste nachdem eine junge
Frau von der Sittenpolizei festgenommen
worden war weil sie angeblich ihr
Kopftuch nicht ordentlich getragen hat
sie starb wenig später unter ungeklärten
Umständen wir sprechen gleich darüber in
dieser Sendung aber zunächst fast
Christina grundgen die aktuelle
Situation zusammen
es sind diese Bilder die das iranische
Regime der Welt gerne zeigt tausende
Menschen auf den Straßen von Teheran in
Solidarität mit der Regierung
ich glaube aus tiefstem Herzen das nach
unserer Scharia der Hijab bleiben sollte
wir brauchen eine ausführliche
Diskussion über den hijob es ist falsch
dass nur die Sittenpolizei regeln zu
lassen aber Frauen sollten wissen dass
dies ein islamisches Land ist jeder der
hier leben will sollte sich an die
Regeln halten vor allem nachts zeigt
sich seit Tagen ein anderes Bild
brennende Polizeiwagen Frauen die ihre
Kopftücher abnehmen und hartes
Durchgreifen der Sicherheitskräfte
mindestens 26 Tote meldet das
Staatsfernsehen wie viele es wirklich
sind lässt sich kaum überprüfen das
Internet ist weitgehend blockiert
mehrere Journalisten wurden festgenommen
beim Freitagsgebet in Teheran ruft
gebetsführer katami die Justiz auf
entschieden gegen die Anführer der
Proteste vorzugehen
hier geht es nicht um das Mädchen hier
geht es darum unsere Religion
anzugreifen den Koran zu verbrennen und
den muslimischen Frauen das Kopftuch
abzunehmen
doch viele werden wohl trotz der
Drohungen weiter demonstrieren auch
heute Abend
das ist unser Thema heute schreibt ihre
und eure Fragen und Kommentare gerne in
die Kommentare und wie immer wenn ihr
die ZDF heute App nutzt per Mail an ZDF
heute-zdf.de in Berlin begrüße ich nun
im Stream Frau Dr
azadeza miriat von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik Frau samiri hat
Dankeschön dass sie sich heute Abend die
Zeit für uns nehmen welche Dynamik
steckt aus ihrer Sicht in dieser
Bewegung
da ist sehr viel Dynamik tatsächlich in
dieser Bewegung allein deswegen weil der
Gegenstand der Proteste ja nun ganz
unmittelbar die Hälfte der Gesellschaft
betrifft nämlich in erster Linie die
Frauen und wir hier zusätzlich auch eine
ethnische Dimension sehen denn die junge
Frau massamini bei mir junge Kurden wo
wir auch eine Reihe von besonders
vielleicht auch gewaltsamen Protesten in
der kurdischen Provinz gesehen haben das
heißt wir sehen hier vor allen Dingen
ein Zusammenspiel von verschiedenen
vielleicht auch Ideen übergreifenden
Kooperation möglicherweise
schichtsübergreifenden Kooperation wir
sehen ja erstmals auch wieder Teile der
Mittelschicht auf die Straße gehen und
es gibt hier eine besondere emotionale
Komponente aufgrund des persönlichen
Schicksals dieser jungen Frau die so
tragisch aus dem Leben gerissen worden
ist das ist eine andere Art der Dynamik
als wir sie beispielsweise den letzten
Jahren im Protesten erlebt haben wo es
vor allen Dingen um wirtschaftliche
Belange gingen und die Wirtschaftsmisere
nun haben wir auch im Beitrag eben
gesehen dass Leute auf die Straße
gegangen sind die für das Kopftuch
demonstriert haben welcher Teil ist denn
repräsentativer für die Mehrheit der
Gesellschaft kann man das sagen
ich glaube schon dass man dazu Aussagen
treffen kann denn es deutet einiges
darauf hin dass ein Großteil der
iranischen Gesellschaft gegen den
Kopftuch Zwang ist darauf deuten ja
sogar in der iranische Erhebung hin das
heißt das nicht nur eine ganze Reihe von
Frauen innerhalb der iranischen
Gesellschaft gegen die Kopftuchpflicht
sind sondern auch eine ganze Reihe von
Männern und im übrigen auch Frauen die
das Kopftuch selber tragen aus dem
islamistischen Milieu beispielsweise die
ist aber für kontraproduktiv halten das
anderen Frauen vergewalt quasi
auferlegen zu wollen also das was wir an
Gegenprotesten hier sehen ist eigentlich
ein ganz gewöhnliches Instrument der
Islamischen Republik dass er auch eine
gewisse Polarisierung suggerieren soll
die aber so gar nicht gegeben ist die
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung sowohl Männer
als auch Frauen spricht sich eigentlich
für eine Selbstbestimmung aus und gegen
einen Kopftuchzwang
endet das in einem Umsturz
es ist tatsächlich jedes Mal so dass
wenn es in Iran Proteste gibt in Iran
die Hoffnung sehr hoch sind und im
Ausland die Erwartungen sehr hoch sind
das ist auch menschlich irgendwo
verständlich ich glaube dass es immer
wenn es zu Protesten in Iran kommt
gerade zu Massenprotesten ein gewisses
Potenzial für stärkere größere
Umwälzungen gibt gleichzeitig sollte man
auch nicht aus dem Blick verlieren
welche Instrumente der Staat hat welche
Maßnahmen dieser Staat ergreifen kann
und in der Vergangenheit auch immer sehr
effektiv ergriffen hat ich glaube aber
auch dass wir unabhängig von möglichen
umsturzsszenarien über andere Szenarien
nachdenken sollten und dies auch wert
sind berücksichtigt zu werden nämlich
das Szenario das selbst wenn diese
Proteste niedergeschlagen werden sollten
möglicherweise etwas größeres daraus
erwächst wir sehen ja derzeit eine ganz
erhebliche öffentliche Debatte was die
kopftuchlicht anbelangt eine Debatte die
nicht nur auf den Straßen sondern auch
in der Politik auch in hard-landkreisen
geführt wird und eine Debatte die som
möglicherweise auch über Proteste hinaus
gesellschaftliche Strahlkraft entwickeln
kann und vielleicht
idealer idealerweise irgendwann auch zu
einer Abschaffung der Kopftuchpflicht
führt auch das wäre ein enorme Erfolg
glaube ich die es wert wäre besprochen
und zelebriert zu werden
wenn ich hier in die Chats gucke dann
sehe ich viel Fragen sind auch zu
internationaler Unterstützung die
beantworten wir auch gleich einen
Kommentar würde ich gerne Vorlesen von
einem Usernamen what is go namens what
is going on der fragt über Youtube oder
sagt über Youtube na wunderbar dass ich
die Männer so viel Gedanken dazu machen
was Frauen tragen dürfen ist das etwas
was sich tatsächlich nur auf das
Kopftuch bezieht nur in
Anführungszeichen oder ist das Kopftuch
am Ende ein Symbol und es geht noch um
viel mehr wofür die Menschen kämpfen
das Kopftuch ist natürlich ein Symbol es
ist sehr viel mehr als nur das Stück
Stoff das Frauen auch ganz pragmatisch
im Alltag einschränkt was wir sehen ist
ja im Grunde genommen ein innere
iranischer Kulturkampf und das ist ein
Kulturkampf der seit über 40 Jahren hier
ausgetragen wird und der jetzt gerade in
einer ganz kritischen Phase dieser
Islamischen Republik vollzogen wird
nämlich in der Phase einer möglichen
transition von der Harmony in die
postharmonie ERA das heißt es wird
vermutlich zeitnah darum gehen einen
Nachfolger für den Revolutionsführer zu
bestimmen und in dieser kritischen Phase
sind ausgerechnet Hardline Kräfte in der
besten wirklichen Ausgangsposition
tatsächlich über die Nachfolge zu
bestimmen und damit auch die Geschicke
dieses Landes potenziell auf Jahrzehnte
hinzuprägen und innerhalb dieser
Hardline Kräfte sehen wir eben sehr
viele selbsterklärte revolutionäre die
ein völlig idealisiertes romantisiertes
Bild der 80er Jahre und auch der
früheren Revolutionszeit haben die in
diesem inner iranischen Kultur Kampf der
von Harmonie auch selbstbewusst geschürt
wird eine Pflicht darin sehen gegen
Andersdenkende gesellschaftliche Kräfte
vorzugehen und quasi die Revolution
vollständig zu verwirklichen das heißt
es geht natürlich um sehr viel mehr als
nur das Kopftuch es steht eben
sinnbildlich auch für diese innen in der
iranische Kultur kann für die wir
ausgetragen sind
dann kommen wir auf den internationalen
Aspekten wie gesagt das ist ein Thema
was was viele hier sehr interessiert
Sven Odenthal fragt zum Beispiel über
Facebook gibt es eine Einschätzung wie
umliegende Staaten oder Großmächte wie
Russland China oder ähnliche Staaten
sich dazu verhalten werden ist zu
erwarten dass es einen Flächenbrand gibt
wie zu Beginn des arabischen Frühlings
also ich glaube von einem Flächenbrand
zu sprechen der jetzt über die
iranischen Grenzen hinausgeht es ist
vermutlich zu früh es ist ja auch nicht
das erste Mal dass wir Protest in Iran
sehen es ist auch nicht das erste Mal in
den letzten zehn Jahren dass wir Protest
in ihren sehen und es ist auch nicht das
erste Mal dass wir Proteste in dieser
Intensität sehen tatsächlich waren
beispielsweise 2019 die Proteste noch
ein Stück intensiver sind noch mehr
Menschen auf die Straße gegangen was
hier natürlich auch noch bevorstehen
kann und auch damals hat es nun keine
transnationalen quasi
Auswirkungen gehabt was China und
Russland und vielleicht andere ja mit
Partner auch der islamische Republik
anbelangt da sollten wir nur nicht
erwarten dass da besonders kritische
Stimmen erhoben worden erhoben werden
würden oder das nur ein druckpolitischer
Art auf die Islamische Republik ausgeübt
wird das ist ja einer der Gründe warum
die Islamische Republik sehr gute
Partnerschaften belastbare
Partnerschaften beispielsweise mit
Russland und China aufrechterhalten kann
weil diese Beziehung eben nicht unter
dem Vorbehalt der Einhaltung von
Menschen Nachrichten stehen und das ist
eben ein pragmatische Aspekt der diese
Beziehung für die Islamische Republik
auch möglich und attraktiv macht
eine Userin namens Marsi Siri fragt über
Youtube oder sagt über Youtube
Iranerinnen und Iraner brauchen
internationale Unterstützung wie sieht
es denn aus mit der internationalen
Unterstützung alles was wir heute von
Olaf Scholz sehen ist ein Tweet in dem
steht das Frauen egal auf der Welt wo
auch immer sie leben nicht unterdrückt
werden dürfen und die EU sucht noch nach
einer gemeinsamen Antwort also wie
müsste eine internationale Reaktion denn
aussehen
also erstmal unterstützt sich das was
die Userin hier sagt das braucht auf
jeden Fall zunächst einmal
internationale Solidarität das ist im
übrigen auch etwas was von der
iranischen Zivilgesellschaft und gerade
von der Frauenbewegung auch oft beklagt
wird dieses Gefühl starker Isolation
dieses Gefühl mangelnder Unterstützung
was natürlich auch durch dieser breit
angelegte Sanktionspolitik der letzten
Jahre noch verstärkt worden ist das
heißt dass Mindeste was es braucht ist
klares Bekenntnis klare Unterstützung zu
der Protestbewegung und zu dem
Selbstbestimmungsrecht hier in diesem
Fall der Frau auf höchster politischer
Ebene international idealerweise
natürlich auch abgestimmt unter
europäischen Akteuren aber man kann
natürlich auch sehr viel mehr machen es
gibt beispielsweise auch Möglichkeiten
der finanziellen direkten aktiven
Unterstützung der iranischen
pflegegesellschaft was ich damit meine
ist nicht unbedingt Finanztransfer an
iranische Organisationen die diese
Organisation ja letztlich nur gefährden
würde sondern beispielsweise auch die
finanzielle Unterstützung von Räumen der
Begegnung in der Italiener Region wo
also Frauen aus der iranischen
Protestbewegung aus auch anderen
arabischen Ländern sich treffen können
zu Konferenzen zu Meetings die Kampagnen
austauschen Strategien entwickeln
Erfahrung austauschen können und sich so
interregional besser vernetzen das ist
ein Wunsch auch aus der iranischen
Zivilgesellschaft und im übrigen auch
der Zivilgesellschaft in der gesamten
Region und das würde auch uns auf
europäischer Seite die Möglichkeit
bieten mit am Tisch zu sitzen denn was
diese iranischen Frauen wirklich
brauchen das wissen Sie am besten selbst
und das hören wir auch am besten von
ihnen selbst
damit ist auch die Frage von Rob über
Youtube beantwortet wie kann man den
Menschen in Iran helfen dann lassen Sie
uns an dieser Stelle mal den Blick
werfen auf die Geschichte der iranischen
Frauenbewegung denn da hat es auch in
der Vergangenheit einiges gegeben
Mitte des 20 Jahrhunderts unter dem
weltlichen jarregime bekommen die Frauen
in Iran mehr Rechte die traditionelle
Kleidung abgeschafft der Schleier sogar
verboten doch seit der islamischen
Revolution 1979 und dem Sturz des Schahs
ist damit Schluss 10000 Frauen aus allen
politischen Lagern protestieren gegen
den geplanten Kopftuchzwang aber die
konservativ religiöse Führung ist
stärker mit den Jahren wächst der Unmut
in der Bevölkerung immer wieder gibt es
heftige Proteste gegen die strengen
Kleriker in den großen Metropolen sehen
viele Frauen die Bekleidungsregeln
mittlerweile eher locker die Regierung
versucht deshalb seit Monaten die
islamischen Gesetze wieder härter
auszulegen trotz all der Unterdrückung
gibt es auch positive Entwicklungen 2019
durften die Frauen zum ersten Mal ein
Fußballspiel im Stadion sehen und der
Frauenanteil an Universitäten hat sich
seit 1979 deutlich erhöht nun fordern
sie vor allem mehr Selbstbestimmung
tja Christian Volk hat das für uns noch
mal zusammengefasst
wir haben schon am Anfang darüber
gesprochen welche Dynamik diese Bewegung
hat aber noch mal speziell mit Blick auf
die Frauen was könnte dieser Protest was
könnte diesen Protest unterscheiden von
dem von anderen Protesten der
Vergangenheit
also ich glaube man muss diesen Protest
schon eigentlich in der gewissen
Kontinuität sehen was frühere Proteste
anbelangt im Film klang das ja gerade
schon an Frauen haben ja schon seit 1979
eigentlich auf begehrt gegen die
Versuche sozusagen ihre Rechte
einzuschränken und das was wir heute
sehen steht ja im Grunde genommen in der
Tradition dieser seit Jahrzehnten
anhaltenden Tradition des aktiven
Widerstands der Frauen und diese
Widerstand zeigt sich ja nicht nur jetzt
heute auf der Straße in Form von
Verbrennungen des Kopftuches oder in
Form dessen dass Frauen sich das
Kopftuch vom Kopf reißen und sich die
Haare abschneiden sondern diese aktive
Widerstand war ja über die letzten
Jahrzehnte eigentlich alltäglich an
allen Ecken und Enden zu sehen denn der
beginnt ja eigentlich schon damit wenn
Frauen das Kopftuch eben nicht so nutzen
dass es die ganzen Haare bedeckt wenn
Frauen kürzere engere Kleidung tragen
wenn Frauen farbige Kopftücher luftigere
Kopftücher tragen das alles sind ja
alltägliche Akte des Widerstandes immer
mit der Gefahr immer mit der Sorge von
der Polizei mitgenommen werden zu können
mit allen möglichen Konsequenzen und
eine dieser Konsequenzen haben wir nun
im Fall von masseamini gesehen das heißt
das was wir heute sehen
sollte eben nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen
dass Frauen sich eigentlich von an
beginnen seit vier Jahrzehnten seit mehr
als vier Jahrzehnten aktiv zur Wehr
setzen und hier nun das vielleicht auch
gewisse Früchte tragen kann ihre aktive
Wege der hat ja schon Früchte getragen
insofern als das ist eine Realität heute
ist dass ein Großteil der iranischen
Frauen eben nicht komplett verschleiert
durch die Straßen gehen und ihre Haare
eben nicht bedecken und wenn diese
Bewegung hier weitergeht wenn sie
weiteren Zuspruch erhält und auch nach
einer möglichen Niederschlagung
gesellschaftspolitische Strahlkraft
weiterentwickeln kann und in sie
investiert wird dann kann das
idealerweise das wäre zumindest
natürlich eine Hoffnung auch zur
Abschaffung dieser Kopftuchpflicht
führen
ich finde ganz interessant was ich
gerade gerade im Youtube Chat für eine
Diskussion entwickelt hier schreibt
einen Usern namens the law ein Großteil
der iranischen Gesellschaft ist sehr
modern aber ein großer Teil ist noch
sehr traditionell das Problem haben
viele Länder wo der glauben eine große
Rolle spielt und darauf antworten andere
User das stimmt zwar aber in anderen
Ländern haben wir das auch wir haben es
zum Beispiel gerade in Amerika wo äh die
Abtreibungen verboten werden wir haben
es in vielen anderen Ländern in der Welt
Afghanistan aber auch hier in
Deutschland gibt es bestimmt genug Leute
die sagen Frauen gehören eher an den
Herd als an die Uni also ist das
eigentlich eine Bewegung die man gar
nicht so sehr auf diesen Glaubensaspekt
beziehen sollte oder ist es tatsächlich
im Iran eine spezielle Geschichte
ich glaube schauen dass ich glaube schon
dass ich das iranische Beispiel doch
noch mal drastisch unterscheidet weil
wir es ja hier mit einem theokratischen
politischen Rahmen zu tun haben also es
geht ihnen nicht nur darum dass der
Glaube eine besondere Rolle spielt
vielleicht im Start sondern es
konstitutiv für die Rechtsprechung im
Staat der Glaube wird als Grundlage
genutzt für eine ganze Reihe von
Einschränkungen in diesem System und er
stellt quasi die Grundlage für diese
gesamte politische Ordnung da insofern
bedeutet auch eine Herausforderung von
bestimmten vielleicht symbolischen
Glaubensfragen wie jetzt in diesem Fall
möglicherweise auch das Kopftuch
gleichermaßen Herausforderung für die
gesamte bestehende Ordnung und das ist
auch noch mal ein Unterschied zu jetzt
anderen vielleicht demokratisch verfasst
starten in denen der Glaube eine Rolle
spielt aber indem wir
zumindest gewisse säkulare Strukturen
sehen die ja in der Islamischen Republik
überhaupt nicht gegeben sind
lassen Sie uns einen Blick auf die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen werfen die
dort im Moment stattfinden was hören Sie
da
also dass wir hören uns sehen ist ja
eigentlich das was wir immer sehen im
Protesten nämlich eine Niederschlagung
von Protesten durch Sicherheitskräfte
man muss dazu sagen dass die Islamische
Republik in diesem Bereich auch stark
aufgerüstet hat seit 2009 seit den
damaligen Massenprotesten im Zuge der
umstrittenen Wiederwahl des damaligen
Präsidenten Mahmut ahmadine jardt es
gibt Spezialeinheiten die speziell für
die Aufstandsbekämpfung ausgebildet sind
und hier aktiv werden darüber hinaus
kann aber die Islamische Republik auch
auf eine Reihe von Freiwilligen Milizen
aus dem islamistischen Milieu
zurückgreifen die sich häufig eben in
Zivil unter die Demonstranten mischen
die mit Knüppeln auf Demonstranten
einschlagen das heißt sie haben einen
einen Mix wenn man so will eine
Kombination aus staatlich formaler
Repression durch Sicherheitskräfte durch
Sondereinsatzkräfte auch der Polizei
gepaart mit freiwilligen Milizen die
sich dann auch noch unter die
Demonstranten mischen und ebenfalls an
der Repression beteiligt sind und das
macht das so besonders schwierig
ist auch das etwas worauf die
internationale Gemeinschaft reagieren
müsste denn wenn niemand reagiert dann
hat man hier das Gefühl diese
Menschenrechtsverletzungen bleiben ohne
Konsequenzen
die Realität ist dass diese
Menschenrechtsverletzung oft ohne
Konsequenzen geblieben sind es gibt
natürlich auf europäischer Seite
beispielsweise nach wie vor Sanktionen
gegenüber Iran die aufgrund von
Menschenrechtsverletzung verhängt worden
sind und das ist auch wichtig und
richtig es braucht ja auch gezielte
Sanktionen die eben diejenigen in der
Islamischen Republik direkt betreffen
den nachgewiesen werden kann dass sie
eben an diesen
Menschenrechtsverletzungen beteiligt
waren sie dann so aus dass sie
beispielsweise Einreiseverbote kriegen
das konnten im Ausland eingefroren
werden also dass das Personen sind die
sich da nicht ohne weiteres frei
außerhalb der iranischen Grenzen
zumindest nicht in der Europäischen
Union aufhalten können es ist aber auch
so dass die Möglichkeit natürlich der
direkten Einflussnahme aus dem Ausland
relativ begrenzt sind was es in jedem
Fall braucht und was wichtig ist ist die
Fokussierung auf all diejenigen
beispielsweise die jetzt verhaftet
werden die in Haft sind den absolut
Willkür droht den Folter und Gewalt
droht und die hier nicht aus dem Blick
geraten dürfen deren Namen bekannt sein
müssen und kontrollieren müssen und wo
eben die internationale
Staatengemeinschaft auch in all ihren
bilateralen
quasi
Zusammenhängen mit der Islamischen
Republik auf diese Person aufmerksam
machen muss sich dafür einsetzen muss
dass diese Person die aus politisch
motivierten Gründen inhaftiert werden
dann auch frei kommen dass sie keiner
Folter ausgesetzt werden aber das heißt
eben dass die Aufmerksamkeit auf diese
Person unbedingt gerichtet bleiben muss
das hat wenn auch einen geringen Effekt
hat ein Effekt und ist deswegen auch so
wichtig
sagt Dr azadé samiriat von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik vielen Dank
dass Sie bei uns in der Sendung waren
danke nach Berlin vielen Dank und wir
gehen noch mal zum Ende der Sendung
weiter nach Istanbul dort ist nämlich
unser Kollege Jörg Brase der über die
Situation in der Region berichtet Jörg
welche aktuellen Informationen hast du
also das was wir gehört haben ist das
habe ich heute morgen in Teheran noch
selbst miterlebt bevor ich dann nach in
die Türkei zurückfliegen musste war halt
dass es Demonstrationen gegeben hat die
die Regierung organisierte also
Unterstützer der Regierung die dann auf
die Straße gegangen sind und die dort
sich beschwert haben die demonstriert
haben gegen die gewaltsamen
Ausschreitungen die es da jetzt gab in
den letzten Tagen der Fokus war da
natürlich vor allem eben auf die
Zerstörungen die Störungen der
Demonstranten und dagegen wollte man
sich wehren Präsident raisi hatte er
aufgerufen dass man hart vorgehen sollte
gegen Chaoten wie er es nannte und
daraufhin hatte die Regierung dann diese
Veranstaltungen heute organisiert nach
dem Freitagsgebet sind 1000 entera auf
die Straße gegangen Frauen in schador
und auch Männer die der Meinung
dass die
Kleidervorschriften die islamischen
Kleidervorschriften halt geltende Regeln
sind die beachtet werden müssen
aber und die sich halt beschwert haben
darüber dass diese Demonstranten den
Sturz der Regierung wollen und den ging
es ja gar nicht um das Kopftuchverbot
also das war die Gegendemonstration die
wir heute morgen gesehen haben und
daraufhin gab es dann wohl auch im Laufe
des Tages auch wieder Demonstrationen
von Regierungsgegnern wo es auch wieder
hunderte von Verhaftungen gegeben haben
soll wie wir hören
was weißt du über Einschränkungen der
Kommunikation das Internet hat ja zum
Teil nicht funktioniert haben wir hier
gehört
ja das war wohl jetzt nicht im ganzen
Land überall gleich aber wir waren ja
die meiste Zeit den Teheran und daraus
in der Tat so dass also vor knapp drei
Tagen das Internet runtergefahren wurde
man hat kaum noch Datenleitung aufbauen
können über die SIM-Karte und auch die
anderen
Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten waren
eingeschränkt soziale Plattform wie
WhatsApp und Instagram wurden ganz
gezielt blockiert da haben wir also
tagelang keine Nachrichten absetzen und
empfangen können und nur über Satelliten
Telefon konnten wir unsere Stücke und
unsere schalten absetzen und dann war es
gestern auch so dass selbst das
blockiert worden ist weil oft man
offensichtlich da eine eine Lücke
entdeckt hat über die immer noch Bilder
und Informationen nach draußen gekommen
sind daraufhin wurden dann wohl
Störsender eingesetzt um diese
Satelliten auch zu stören das heißt wir
mussten dann gestern per Telefon
schalten weil wir aus Iran mit unseren
Videosignalen überhaupt nicht mal
rausgekommen sind
du beobachtest die iranische
Gesellschaft und Politik sehr intensiv
was ist deine Einschätzung auf der einen
Seite sehen wir diese Menschen auf der
Straße die ihr Leben riskieren auf der
anderen Seite hat man das Gefühl es gibt
auch viele Menschen die quasi
abgeschlossen haben und versuchen
irgendwie so weit sie können in Ruhe ihr
Leben zu leben fernab der Politik und
was sie nicht wollen ist eine große
Revolution mit tausenden von Toten was
glaubst du was überwiegt am Ende
also das ist schwer zu sagen ich meine
mir wird die Frage natürlich ständig
gestellt kann das jetzt dem Regime
gefährlich werden das sehe ich der sie
jetzt auch regelmäßig Iran bereist sehe
das nicht natürlich sind die Leute mit
denen ich spreche
größtenteils gegen die Politik die dort
gemacht wird aber nicht notwendigerweise
für einen Sturz der Regierung das sind
natürlich viele das kann man gar nicht
abstreiten aber wenn geglaubt wird im
Ausland dass wir da jetzt eine Mehrheit
finden die die Regierung stürzen will da
bin ich mir nicht so sicher in der Tat
viele wollen Reformen und das ist auch
das neue jetzt an dieser Bewegung dass
dieser Tod von Massa Amini doch so
emotional war und so viele Menschen
betroffen und schockiert damit zwar
nicht nur
Regierungsgegner sondern teilweise auch
Leute aus dem konservativen Lager dass
da jetzt einige auf die Straße gegangen
sind die sonst vielleicht nicht gegen
die Regierung auf die Straße gehen
würden und gesagt haben das war jetzt zu
viel und insofern gibt es einige
Experten die der Meinung sind dass es
durchaus Potenzial gibt um jetzt sage
ich mal Reformen zu diskutieren im
Parlament das wird wohl auch gemacht
dass man darüber diskutiert ob man diese
Sittenpolizei einschränkt in ihren
Kompetenzen dass sie nicht mehr so hart
vorgehen soll gegen Frauen dass das dass
der Verstoß gegen den Kopftuchzwang das
verstößer dagegen nicht mehr
kriminalisiert werden dass Frauen also
festgenommen werden dass Frauen auf
Polizeistation transportiert werden und
da dann noch mal belehrt werden also da
scheint es jetzt im Moment Bewegung zu
geben Diskussionen zu geben ob man an
diesen Regeln etwas ändert aber es geht
nicht grundsätzlich darum jetzt das
Kopftuch abzuschaffen und vor allem
jetzt auch jetzt nicht darum die
Regierung zu stürzen das sehe ich also
sehe ich nicht aber vielleicht gibt es
das Potenzial tatsächlich um sage ich
mal kleinere Reformen und Veränderungen
durchzusetzen
hier in den Chats gibt es viel
Diskussionen zum Thema Religion und
Staat aber das würde eine eine eigene
Sendung füllen darum noch eine letzte
Frage an dich hier ist die Frage über
Youtube wie lange wird dieser Zustand
anhalten bis alles blutig
niedergeschlagen wird wir erleben das ja
schon jetzt aber wird das Regime noch
brutaler gegen die eigene Bevölkerung
vorgehen
also das müssen wir leider befürchten
denn es ist so dass Präsident reisi
gestern seine Botschaft gesendet hat aus
den USA hat gesagt Friedrich
demonstrieren ja Chaos nein die
Geheimdienste haben dann heute noch mal
dazu aufgerufen den Protesten fern zu
bleiben und das kann man dann durchaus
deuten als sage ich mal den Schießbefehl
man wir haben ja 2019 große landesweite
Proteste gegen die Aufhebung der
benzinsubventionen gesehen da soll es
bis zu 1.500 Tote gegeben haben das
heißt das Regime schreckt auch nicht
davor zurück wenn es sein muss und wenn
es seine eigene
existenzgefährdet sieht dann eben auch
brutal gegen das eigene Volk vorzugehen
deshalb müssen wir befürchten wenn diese
Demonstration jetzt weitergehen dass wir
leider noch wahrscheinlich sehr viel
mehr Opfer sehen werden und insofern
muss man jetzt mal hoffen dass naja ich
meine wir wollen jetzt nicht hoffen dass
die Proteste und die Inhalte für die da
protestiert wird bestehen in
Vergessenheit geraten auch nicht die
Leute das haben wir eben gehört die
jetzt verhaftet sind das muss natürlich
weiter verfolgen aber ich fürchte das
Regime wird alles daran setzen um
sicherzustellen dass diese Proteste so
schnell wie möglich enden
vielen Dank Jörg Brase nach Istanbul
und wir enden diesen Stream mit einem
User Kommentar noch mal von the law über
Youtube Respekt für den Mut der Frauen
in Iran in diesem Sinne vielen Dank fürs
Fragen fürs mitdiskutieren fürs
kommentieren und zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss